from high gas prices to canceled flights
summer vacation season is turning into a
nightmare for so many travelers
the pandemic prices were great whereas
like two dollars a flight right now the
flights are skyrocketing and it's
getting out of hand the border
protection was just like the it was just
like so long we were standing there for
like
90 minutes oh man this is crazy man i
got to start the pump twice just to fill
the tank up it's
it hurts double
but there may be a solution a staycation
the latest issue of conde nast traveler
includes staycation ideas for the summer
executive editor aaron florio joins us
with some tips for planning your perfect
local vacation vacation erin good
morning to you we all know the reasons i
mean we don't want to deal with those
flight cancellations and all of that but
you say if people are doing a staycation
they're kind of doing it the wrong way
and not really focusing on that vacation
part well i think i mean i think the
unfortunate news is that you know this
was supposed to be the summer of revenge
travel and everybody was so excited to
get back out there and now we've had to
change our plans again um i think covert
taught us to be flexible which is a good
thing now the important thing to
remember is a staycation does not mean
you're not having a vacation there is a
totally legitimate and great way to stay
close to home or in some cases even at
home and turn it into something that
feels like you've gone miles away you've
really removed yourself from your daily
life you've got to change it up at least
a little bit you do so you do that in
part by redesigning your backyard in a
way that can feel fun and luxurious well
i mean i think that's part of it that's
certainly part of it um you know there
there are so many great products out
there for people to to buy and sort of
transform their backyard into this kind
of like vacation paradise you know uh if
you weren't able to get to the national
parks or make it to the camping site
that you're planning to bring your kids
to i mean a good idea is to you know buy
a tent put it up in your backyard i
didn't like that i'm gonna do that i saw
the picture and i was like for sure yeah
i mean it's it's really easy also what i
think is really great about it is that
you can still do it next year you can
take that big camping trip next year but
this means you're sort of giving your
kids a bit of a primer into this like a
warm-up a bit of a warm-up and also the
cat the kitchen facilities the bathroom
facility
[Laughter]
yeah and if you really want to up the
ante you can get outdoor fire pits i
mean you can really go big right okay so
speaking of uh kitchens uh i'm a foodie
so when most people go on vacations
they're looking at the weather the
nearest beaches for me it's all about
the menus so you're saying there's a way
to bring the food that you like on
vacation
home
absolutely and
and i think it actually goes two ways i
think you can bring the food you travel
for home to you and i think you can also
stay home and go a small distance and
find the food that you would get on a
plane for so my first if i love this i
don't know if any of you have ever used
gold belly yes gold billy is fantastic
what is it i don't know it's essentially
like a restaurant delivery from the
entire country delivering nationwide so
let's say you had planned this great
getaway in the northeast in new england
you couldn't make it this summer you can
go and get a great seafood feast clam
chowder lobster rolls from legal
seafoods in boston get it delivered to
you in idaho what yeah yeah blue
mountain hotties
chicago pizza exactly it's amazing it's
amazing i mean one thing i will say is
obviously it's not going to reach you in
an hour uh you do need to plan in
advance but it can make you feel like
you've traveled somewhere while you've
been staying home also one of the things
you said that i like hotels like find
hotel deals maybe around you and that
gives you that vacation yes i mean i
think one of the most important things
to making you feel like you're properly
on vacation is actually getting out of
your environment even if you stay in
your hometown don't stay at home um
it's really easy actually to find hotel
deals in summer uh you know be flexible
uh you know don't think of a weekend as
a saturday and sunday think of it as a
tuesday and wednesday you're gonna find
great deals i mean there are some hotels
in new york city that are hundreds of
dollars cheaper midweek another tip i
always tell people is get on the phone
and talk to the hotel directly you never
know what you might be able to negotiate
when you get a human on the phone
instead of dealing with a third-party
booking agent and finally if you're not
in a city but you're close by consider
going to a city for your holiday instead
of to the coast or to the park because
the city's empty out and the hotel rates
drop with with that these are some good
tips there's so many good ideas here i
mean i mean just staying in your house
you spend so much time getting your
house the way you want it and then you
leave it for down time and like you
should spend your downtime in it you and
your spouse can take turns handing each
other warm towels
and you kind of owe it to yourself too
you know like treat yourself a little
bit even if you're staying home right
yeah there's no place like home that's
what we say aaron florio thank you so
much thank you